how's it going guys we're gonna look at
the adapter pattern today here on
codetech tutorials my name is matt and
uh if you've seen the previous facade
episode it's a lot like that essentially
we just take something and we kind of
conform it to a new interface the big
difference here with adapter though is
that this new interface uh is adapted to
match some required interface and that's
about it so i'm going to do a kind of a
silly example here in our code and uh
that hopefully clears up for people so
let's jump over to the code shall we
here we go so i made a new folder over
here and uh i'm gonna put it to my usual
side uh yeah just an adapter folder and
added it to the cmake and all that stuff
uh so you'll see that but i haven't
really updated this one too much yet it
looks like it's got the main i've got
adapter
i've got this whole class here but it's
not really i'm going to kind of uh do a
new fresh example here so i'm going to
delete all that but uh
and we'll delete all this say you say
you have an interface
we'll say the interface or the thing you
want is a cheeseburger you want a
cheeseburger man it's got to have cheese
on it burger however
you're working with uh some sort of
thing
that only makes hamburgers so uh you
don't want to have to like reinvent the
wheel redo the bun and the meat and all
that stuff so you just want to reuse the
hamburger but add cheese to it and
that's how it would fit your design so
let's type up a few things here let's
first make a struct
of a hamburger but how are we going to
represent this and data so
we could just do we could do strings
that
forget strings you know
strings are uh
sure strings are very detailed you can
say lots of stuff but we're just going
to put has like bull has uh has bun um
yeah pickle's good
yes pickle what else do they have as a
ketchup
ketchup
all right but notice that there's no
option for cheese here well we could
default the base ones to true and make
you have to construct the rest as if
needed
and then maybe you have an interface for
this struct that is
something like uh let's make a quick
interface here make a deleter here make
this destructor
equal defaults
and then we also probably want in here
something to wrap the hamburger
uh or something like that so we're to
have it return a hamburger
um
and just say a burger
now we'll just like return a hamburger
or i guess we could go something like uh
hamburger
and you know we probably want to take in
different options here for how they want
it but i'm kind of skipping that for um
simplicity reasons but naturally you
would need the details about what they
want on it so you probably pass that all
in here like like a bunch of bowls like
a pickle question you know something
like that has pickle extra pickle
whatever whatever your options are or
maybe you'll just you know whatever you
decide to do it's fine but we're not
going to worry about that because it'll
just uh take too much time and it's not
super relevant to the rest of the
example that i'm going to show you so
then we would just return this burger
this is not super efficient code
you're going to notice that there's
going to be a lot of copying and stuff
but it doesn't really matter so
basically we can make you a make burger
and it's going to return us
the hamburger in its default state all
right but what if
they want a cheeseburger and you don't
want to have to reinvent the wheel so
instead you just go okay well let's just
make a cheeseburger version and this
would be like a cheeseburger adapter
really a cheeseburger just has cheeks
that's that's the only difference so
there's a couple different things you
could do here uh for example uh within
our class privately we could go uh
struct cheeseburger
carrots from
uh hamburger except it also has
cheese and we'll just set that to true
by default
you know just like so
boom so we got another structure
cheeseburger now uh obviously they
probably want access to this so maybe we
put this outside of it something like
that
but uh it just depends on your your
program but essentially this
cheeseburger maker is gonna be the same
thing as the hamburger maker except it's
also just going to add cheese but you
know there's always going to be that
person that says yeah i'd like a
cheeseburger without cheese please and
you come over the intercom and say you
mean a hamburger and they're like no no
no i wanted the cheeseburger i just
don't want the cheese like that's a
hamburger no i want to cheat and you
know people people are not too bright
out there in the public sometimes
uh so
anyway make what you know that uh it's
kind of besides the point but the point
is sometimes you got to make a
cheeseburger
and set the has cheese to false because
people are adamant that they want to be
charged more for a hamburger so
it is what it is so
we got a couple different ways of doing
this one of the ways we can do this is
we can make a private variable
of this hamburger maker so private here
we can go
hamburger
maker
essentially
you can make a constructor here on
cheeseburger maker that takes a
hamburger maker
that way you could make the hamburger
you could pass it into here and this
thing would do the thing with it you go
hamburger eagles you could do something
like that and you could set it and have
it own this new memory and
basically got the hamburger maker so
then when you call make burger from this
one you don't want to
return that you want to
turn a cheeseburger instead of a
hamburger right so
this one we're going to make a different
function we're going to call make burger
and we're going to
return
well a cheeseburger not
but the cheeseburger is just a hamburger
so we would just go okay let's make this
cheeseburger uh c burger
and that would be it really actually in
this case i mean if we're not handling
passing in the ingredients like we
should be just to save time
once again
then this would be enough because
essentially we get everything on the
hamburger and we also add that cheese so
it'd be a beautiful thing and this would
all be all you need to adapt your
hamburger
into a cheeseburger let's make a little
mane here and uh we'll just
include or let's see here how are we
going to do this
uh we'll first start out with a
cheeseburger so or a hamburger so say
you want a hamburger we'll just call it
the
peach burger
each underscore and we're gonna make
this one well first of all we need a
hamburger maker hp maker
and we'll call uh hb maker dot egg
burger you know that's going to return a
hamburger so this would set this one
accurately and there you go got your
hamburger so yeah that's fine but now
what if you get uh something that wants
the cheeseburger this is where you need
to adapt that hamburger and not reinvent
everything just because a new sandwich
so
um so
say you need a cheeseburger this time of
course you can't just call
hamburger maker because you're going to
get the wrong type
and it's not going to work exactly as
you require uh okay let's name this one
c burger so instead you're going to need
the adapted
class that you made which is this
cheeseburger maker that's the adaptive
class uh
cb maker
and this one you're just going to go cb
maker dot make burger
and there's our little adapted first
herb
typos uh what doesn't it like about this
no default constructor exists okay so we
got to take a look at that real quick uh
this is true there is no default
constructor so we got to think about
that a little bit this once it wants a
hamburger to start now this doesn't
actually really make any sense because
we don't actually do anything with this
so maybe it'd make more sense to do
something like uh we'd have to use this
constructor first of all so we'll fix
that in a second but then instead of
just directly making a cheeseburger
first
well we make the hamburger so whatever
the ingredients are on that is would be
the idea because this hamburger maker
would in theory be taking in uh some
ingredients there but once again we're
kind of skipping over that so this would
basically say you already made the
hamburger just add the cheese because
that kind of thing that makes sense so
uh we go amber dot nate make the burger
and that would be a hamburger
but we could also say
we could also cast this to a
cheeseburger
i'm making this way too confused let's
just try it let's just see what happens
so if we make the burger and return it
we're not going to get a cheeseburger
but we could go static
cast cheeseburger
whatever it makes
and we return the c burger so if we
stack cast it we should have the cheese
now this is uh maybe a little advanced
here because the static casting but
essentially because of this whole
inheritance structure right here we
could call a cheeseburger a hamburger
and that's why this static cast would
work we basically say okay we're making
a hamburger but we're going to call it
cheeseburger and that should construct
it with this has cheese true on there
and then we just return it so in that
case we are using this original
hamburger here or the hamburger maker
all right let's go back to our main
and now we got this cheeseburger maker
but now we need to pass in and hit the
ham and look at my cheeseburger maker
again he wants a hamburger maker
uh once the maker doesn't want the
actual hamburger so that's sort of
interesting maybe we actually want not
the maker but the hamburger i don't know
yeah i guess you could go either way but
basically we want the hp maker here
and we don't even want to make this
burger necessarily um and then then and
then this reference should work because
it's the right type now it was a long
time
and uh there we go so we've got this
hamburger maker and we've adapted it to
a cheeseburger maker like so and then we
should get uh let's just make sure it
has cheese because that's that's the big
thing
has cheese
[Music]
okay so let's see if this cheeseburger
actually has cheese like what i'm to put
this
into uh
release probably should have been doing
this before unless you need to step
through the code you probably want to be
in release in general
there we go we should get our new one up
here for adapter there it is and let's
just see if it says as cheese as she's
true very good that means it's working
as intended so that is one way of doing
it that is uh you know basically you
would follow this sort of pattern you
know basically you already have an
interface but it doesn't work for what
you're trying to do so you need to adapt
it something like this adaption there's
a lot of other examples this is used
extremely commonly people do sort of
this sort of stuff all the time
sometimes they don't even realize what
it's called they're just kind of doing
it because that's how they get it to
work so if you're basically adapting
something to get it to work with a new
class or something like that it's an
adapter hence the word so i want to
reiterate that this is not the only way
of doing it do a google search for like
exact adapter examples in c plus you'll
find a bunch of others i just wanted to
come up with something on my own uh that
way i'm not copying from the internet
too much but the reality of these
patterns is they are very well known and
very well uh i don't know
instructed i guess so it's not there's
no way for me to reinvent the wheel or
say that i'm the one who created this or
anything like this it's just something
that's been around for ages and ages and
uh
hope that makes sense and helps you
understand the basic concept
of what an adapter is obviously in real
code you're not going to be doing
cheeseburger hamburger stuff you'll be
doing like
um i don't know
do does this does this matrix need to be
in column major or row major form and
stuff like that so it's going to of
course a little more mathematical but
you could uh make an adapter for that if
you've got something that's bringing
some library that's bringing in matrices
in the wrong form could make an adapter
for it and change it to the correct form
and stuff like that for literally
anything so there you go hope you
enjoyed see you guys in the next one
peace out
[Music]